a few days ago a racially insensitive
email surfaced from UVA board president
Sybil Reynolds
the email contained comments about me
I haven't spoken out in public until now
and here to join me as I do so is the
woman who wrote those comments
uba board president civil Reynolds thank
you for being here thank you for having
me on
I know there was some fuhrer
well-deserved over the statement that
uba issued some days ago
it was
inadequate to say the very least the
mistake was mine
and mine alone and I'm here to apologize
in person
I am deeply sorry
for what I said even in the heat of a
contentious hiring decision nothing
can excuse what I said you mean calling
me Aunt Jemima
I didn't exactly call you dance
um I want to set the record straight
now you know that Aunt Jemima was on
boxes of pancake mix and not cereal
right I guess I know that now
but this is about more than just an
offhand comment the irony of your joke
is that the Pearl Milling Company used
the image and likeness of a black woman
to sell a brand
I'm sure with no profit participation my
question is what brand am I helping uba
to sell in your eyes look
words matter actions matter more and uba
has been sorely inactive when it comes
to equity and inclusion now the board
isn't involved with day-to-day
operations we leave that to the capable
leadership of our CEO
but when that leadership
Walters I have a duty to step in don't
you
you've oh he deserves them
but let's talk about stepping in what
would that look like do you even think
it's possible to win back the trust of
uba's employees
you know something
I do
I do think it's possible and it'll start
with a dialogue between uba employees
and the board from now on you all will
have a voice at every single board
meeting now is the time for transparency
that's great to hear truly
in the interest of transparency
was I hired for a permanent anchor
position because I am black
like not no
[Music]
you used a clumsy racist comment to
complain about my hiring did you think I
wasn't qualified was that it
well now in point of fact at that time I
did not believe you were qualified let
me rephrase you were untested well
that's not exactly true were you aware
that I was q-tested
more than any other person who has ever
anchored the show
that I had to have eight different
approval meetings in addition to the
strategy discussions about my hair I was
unaware and I still found time to
spend weekends with four former anchors
developing my on-air skills well now
that that is impressive it's very
admirable that aside I don't understand
why you used a racialized image when
discussing me
is that how you see me
is that
how you see us
foreign
career reduced to one unthinking
bone-headed thing you said in an email
haven't you ever said anything uh that
later you came to regret when speaking
casually you're in a leadership position
at this network and on your watch
you let employees of color be
systematically devalued
is that something to be casual about
Donnie tell the camera to push in on
Sybil and keep pushing until I see her
pores we're supposed to break you want
me to cut no no okay camera two push in
closer no
I was careless and there isn't any
excuse but you have to understand we
don't just give this opportunity to
anyone
anyone who sits in that chair has to be
grateful as
there it is
I should be grateful that that your job
is so very hard to get
I want to say as for uba as an
institution going forward I think we've
we should move on from this climate
where racial divisions are exploited but
that's every climate though wouldn't you
say
um
but yes we will move on from
institutional racism right after this
break